[Música]
la ira de china y muchísima expectativa
a nivel internacional ha generado la
llegada de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi a
taipei la capital de taiwán oficialmente
llamada república de china está parada
hace parte de una gira de pelosi que
adelanta por el continente asiático y se
trata también de la primera visita en
los últimos 25 años que es realizada por
un presidente de la cámara de
representantes la cámara baja del
congreso de eeuu días previos al
aterrizaje de pelosi la república
popular de china y su gobierno en
beijing rechazó la llegada de la
representante y también advirtió sobre
las serias repercusiones que podría
tener esto para la región y para la
región entre y para la relación entre
beijing y taipei y washington de hecho
china ya anunció que su ejército va a
comenzar a realizar operaciones
militares dirigidas al alrededor de la
isla en respuesta precisamente a esta
visita de pelosi
pues a través de su cuenta en twitter
nancy pelosi reiteró ese compromiso
histórico que su país ha tenido con la
isla de formosa por lo que su visita
desde su punto de vista es completamente
válida veamos
otra visita es una de varias
delegaciones del congreso a taiwán y de
ninguna manera contradice la política de
larga data de los eeuu guiada por la ley
de relaciones con taiwán de 1979 los
comunicados conjuntos de eeuu y china y
las seis garantías
bueno pero desde la otra orilla del
estrecho la respuesta fue muy clara y
calificaron los hechos como una escalada
así lo indicó wang jing la portavoz del
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
la república popular de china escuchemos
creo que está muy claro para el mundo
que es estados unidos el que está
tomando medidas de provocación causando
tensiones en el estrecho de taiwán eeuu
debe asumir toda la responsabilidad por
esta escalada
porque esta isla en el mar de china está
generando tanto conflicto y porque eeuu
parece estár retando a esas advertencias
de beijing y que está igual pues los voy
a poner en contexto con algunos datos
muy básicos la república de china como
se le conoce oficialmente a nivel
internacional es conocida más
popularmente como taiwán para no
confundir la precisamente con la
república popular de china que es
gobernada desde beijing su capital como
lo decía en la ciudad de taipei y tiene
unos 23 millones de habitantes es
considerada por beijing como una
provincia separatista para este gobierno
comunista taiwán es parte de su
territorio y aboga por la incorporación
bajo el formato que es una de las
opciones un formato de un país dos
sistemas algo parecido como lo que ya
hicieron con hong kong y con macao y que
tal vez a taiwán no le convence mucho el
gobierno taiwanés se considera a sí
mismo y considera su territorio como un
estado soberano pero oficialmente no ha
proclamado su independencia de la china
continental y es por eso que el estatus
legal a nivel internacional es muy
confuso actualmente solamente 15 países
reconocen a taiwán como un estado
independiente tiene su propia
constitución es una democracia
consolidada con líderes políticos que
son elegidos en las urnas es una
economía capitalista plenamente abierta
al mundo y tiene unas 300 mil tropas
activas como parte de sus fuerzas
armadas último dato en 1971 la república
de china es decir taiwán fue expulsada
de la organización de naciones unidas
porque este organismo internacional le
dio el reconocimiento diplomático a
beijing es decir a la república popular
de china
pues muy bien hoy en el debate de france
24 entonces vamos a analizar lo que
podría ocurrir a raíz de esta visita de
nancy pelosi y lo que puede significar
esto para la región y bueno para el
mundo entero para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos en el estudio a lina luna
ella es sinóloga internacionalista de la
universidad externado de colombia y
también nos acompaña en el estudio hoy
casa llena aquí en el estudio de france
24 jose alejandro zepeda docente de
relaciones internacionales de la
pontificia universidad javeriana que
está ubicada también en la ciudad de
bogotá les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todas las preguntas comentarios
que ustedes deseen a través de las redes
sociales estamos en twitter en instagram
y en facebook donde no se encuentran
como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
también en youtube pueden ver la señal
en streaming de este programa de la
programación de france 24 también ya
para terminar rápidamente saluda a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que nos escuchen de todos nuestros
contenidos ya están disponibles en apple
en spotify deezer
muy bien ahora sí a lo que vinimos a
conversar sobre este tema le doy
entonces la palabra li na li na
bienvenida al programa como siempre un
gusto tenerla con nosotros y punto de
partida la primera pregunta para conocer
opiniones sobre este tema y que detrás
de esta visita de pelosi y cuáles son
las verdaderas intenciones de washington
al mandar a la representante pelo se ata
el pecho a ver no podemos minimizar esta
visita a veces los en eeuu está diciendo
ahí tenemos derecho a ir a donde
queramos no es nada oficial pero tenemos
que tener en cuenta que pelosi es la que
seguiría al mando si falta baile nos
estamos hablando de que es un nivel muy
muy alto es un funcionario es una
funcionaria pues de un nivel muy alto y
esto claramente iría en contra de los
cuatro no es que son los acuerdos que se
hicieron entre estados unidos y china en
1979 que era precisamente que cualquier
relacionamiento con taiwán se hacía a
través de china es decir podían tener
acercamientos culturales económicos
ese tipo de cosas pero no políticos sino
de este nivel no entonces en ese sentido
para china claramente hay una ofensa ahí
taiwán
es
desafortunadamente una ficha más que le
funciona eeuu para desestabilizar a los
poderes que considera le pueden estar
amenazando su hegemonía
y yo creo que no podemos
descontextualizar lo que está pasando
con un poco lo que vimos que ha pasado
hace poco con ucrania también sí es
decir hay unas dinámicas muy similares
de diplomacia ofensiva de una de una
postura poco
pacífica no y de hecho como lo dijo el
comunicado
chino del ministerio de relaciones
exteriores el que juega con fuego
probablemente salga quemado entonces es
taiwán se ha convertido como en ésta en
esta nueva ficha con la cual se busca a
tensionar más las relaciones con china
hablando de no es para reafirmar nuestro
apoyo a la democracia de nuestros amigos
pero pues va a ir en esta base poquito
haciendo lo mismo que necesidad de que
ahora venga pelosi también hacerlo nada
más una llamada de casi dos horas entre
los dos presidentes hablando sobre este
tema llevo muchas advertencias por parte
de beijing vamos ahora a conocer la
opinión de josé alejandro del otro lado
de la mesa no se alejan dro bienvenido
también gusta tenerlo acá con nosotros
punto de partida que cree usted que
detrás de esta visita y por qué eeuu
desafía esas advertencias de beijing
bueno gusto estar con ustedes aquí con
toda la audiencia yo creo que estamos
viviendo un año justamente complicado
este 2022 en que ya sumamos justamente
un mundo que todavía frente al quabit a
la guerra justamente entre ucrania rusia
yo creo estamos viendo es como una
suerte de ajedrez de este mundo
bipolar después
de la guerra fría a un nuevo marco de
darle sentido al sistema internacional
en el siglo 21 yo creo que estamos
volviendo un poco al realismo
desafortunadamente el idealismo está
quedando un poco atrás no estamos en las
mejores épocas para lo mismo y los
grandes actores están marcando
territorios están marcando las fichas en
el sistema internacional y yo creo que
eeuu ha querido también justamente
bailén y una manera encubierta o
indirecta volver a posicionar en la
marca de eeuu el sistema internacional
que venía siendo muy golpeada por la
contradictoria política internacional
del gobierno de donald trump sí y por el
otro lado pues china también estaba
defendiendo lo suyo porque volveríamos
un poco a repetir eventualmente lo mismo
no dos pelea david contra goliat que
sería ucrania rusia ahora en este caso
taiwán contra china pero creo que hay
que también hacer un llamado a la calma
tenemos que tener también una
comprensión mucho más sensible y yo creo
que justamente es el momento de entender
nuestras posiciones desde occidente pero
también como piensa la china como piensa
los pueblos de asia el oriente etcétera
que se salen a veces de nuestro marco de
comprensión para entender por qué ellos
reaccionan de esta manera claro y que
tiene unos intereses particulares que en
muchos casos nosotros desde occidente no
entendemos usted toca voy a continuar
con jose alejandro ya le doy la palabra
línea y toca el tema de la política
exterior de eeuu que venía trastocada
después del gobierno de donald trump
como se están rotando entonces esta
política del presidente debate porque
también ha sido muy criticado por medios
estadounidenses e internacionales que
nadie entiende que lo que está haciendo
yo creo que viene de primero de
justamente esa crisis interna porque
eeuu guste o no es una de las
democracias más importantes del mundo en
los últimos dos siglos y esa crisis
interna en que mucha gente pone en duda
el modelo de pluralismo por el cual eeuu
pues se convirtió en un país de american
dream' y democracia etcétera pues tanto
recuperarlo ya vai de nuevo demasiado
exitoso pero ha tratado de generar una
nueva una nueva liga de apoyo a la
democracia que sustenta eventualmente
las palabras de nancy pelosi pero por
otro lado pues mientras eso se juega por
otro lado está el posicionamiento que
tiene que tener toda toda potencia
internacional de gran nivel y ellos no
lo van a dejar de ser lesiva y de no
apuran este en este juego pues
eventualmente también puede pasar que le
van a dar se le va a restar su gobierno
va a ser reelegido y lo que haga ahora
no va a poder no lo podrán ser naciones
para gran ruta da nuevamente repito esa
marca democrática eeuu pero sin dejar de
lado los intereses del realismo pero
también tengamos en cuenta que hay
elecciones de medio término que les va a
pasar factura a los demócratas a final
de año lina en eso es lo que vemos desde
el lado de eeuu lo que puede ser o
entender esa política exterior es lo que
intentan hacer con este movimiento en
china pero viendo una china continental
un territorio tan vasto con una economía
tan fuerte porque este particular
interés por esta isla que está al frente
de ellos a ciento y pico de kilómetros
que aparentemente no tiene mayores
recursos porque es tan importante en
esencia política
a ver la historia de taiwán es que
taiwán existe también mucho por la
influencia eeuu básicamente cuando gana
la repubblica osa cuando canal el
ejército popular de liberación que de
hecho va a notar están celebrando ahora
el primero de agosto su fundación o sea
que es un momento complejo porque todas
las armas están afuera todos los
desfiles están sucediendo y preciso
viene pelosi a taiwán no creo que sea
una coincidencia
pero cuando gana el ejército comunista
entonces el kuomintang no quiere aceptar
esta derrota la va a aceptar pero eeuu
tampoco quiere que la acepte porque no
era el plan de en la cabeza eeuu eeuu
tenía como plan para contener a rusia
que era evidente que la unión que venía
a la fe que la guerra fría pues esperaba
que china se uniera a su a su ligada a
su liga de aliados y entonces como
acaban de liberar la isla de formosa le
dice a chang kai-chek váyanse a la isla
de formosa con el objetivo de red
digamos de reforzarlos para retomar
después el continente es decir que
taiwán fue creado como un rechazo al
triunfo comunista y con el objetivo de
después dominar el continente y eso hay
que tenerlo claro si es una propia es
una es bueno para china es una provincia
para los taiwaneses son ser república
que se crea con el objetivo de no
reconocer el gobierno que gana el
gobierno comunista y con el objetivo de
recuperar la china continental entonces
eso ya nos marca un punto de partida no
conciliador y eso también recordemos que
es una china que hasta ese momento es la
primera vez que logra estar sin
invasores desde 1842 china empezó toda
la época de humillación y derrota donde
la invadió todo el mundo de eeuu de
francia alemania japón inglaterra japón
9 rusia todo el mundo la invadió
entonces china es la primera vez y eso
se vuelve una bandera de la china
unificada gran cierto y cuando cuando
ganó el partido comunista taiwán era
parte de china punto sí entonces en ese
sentido para china es un tema de no hay
duda de que taiwán es parte de china sí
pero todavía se mantiene ese sentimiento
de que desde taiwán pueden llegar a la
china continental para para intentar
hacer un cambio político allí como se
creía en el momento que fue creado y
cuando fuera sacados allí los que
perdieron este conflicto interno no no
el ejército es indudablemente muchísimo
mayor pero el problema si éstos y taiwán
estuviera solo sería como todo bien el
problema es que estados unidos detrás de
eeuu ha vendido creo que son 700
millones de dólares en armas misiles
intercontinentales a taiwán en el último
año
la presidente de taiwán de hecho
reconoció que eeuu lleva un año
como se llama estables y fortaleciendo
el ejército y capacitando a los
militares taiwaneses y ahora esta visita
entonces no podemos deseos el pobre
taiwán es una ficha más que después va a
quedar destrozado si esto explotará en
un conflicto pero para china esto es un
mensaje claro de eeuu de decir estamos
dándolo en las fuerzas da igual sí
entonces es tocar la peor herida que se
le puede tocar a china es una herida muy
muy importante la atención ya está
clarísima el aumento de la atención
entre washington y beijing es
completamente evidente por las
respuestas que han dado los dos países
esto genera algún tipo de fractura
genera algún tipo de rompimiento de la
presencia de eeuu en la región relación
entre los dos países y extiendo un poco
más la pregunta china puede que no
reaccione de inmediato mañana no haga
absolutamente nada pero en ese mediano
plazo que puede hacer china como un
proceso de altas de civilización
obviamente siempre y como alertas
tempranas y ésta la primera hacer estas
demostraciones de fuerza a navegar de
circunnavegar uno de los temas más
interesantes es justamente geopolítica
es como las islas se defienden y se
buscan desde las pequeñas ciudades
rodeadas de agua como era la venecia
hace cinco siglos a la manhattan de
ahora oa la inglaterra o al japón o a
taiwán entonces yo creo que por ahora
estamos en plena ronda de ejercicios
pero también falta a ver qué pasa cuál
es el desenlace también con la guerra
rusa rusia a ucrania porque china apoya
a rusia pero también son rivales
entonces hay falta y falta a ver qué
pasaría cómo termina esto para ver qué
acuerdo llegamos china ha tratado de ser
muy prudente y yo creo que china tampoco
le interesa ahorita va a meterse en un
conflicto y llegar a escalar pero sin
duda alguna si llegara a ver un posible
desencuentro mayor ellos podrían llegar
a tomar ciertas siete ciertas posiciones
militares que lo que esperemos no no sé
de ningún tipo de escaramuzas repito
todavía y yo creo que ahorita el mundo
está bien no están preparados o no
estamos preparados para dar un paso a
iniciar otra guerra o unas
circunstancias bélicas en este
calendario que vivimos de donde mentido
es tan complicado lina y entendiendo esa
dinámica y la forma de actuar de china
como podrían responder ellos para
complementar la respuesta de josé
alejandro entendiendo que en los otros
escenarios en donde eeuu y china han
tenido que chocar precisamente por el
tema de taiwán china era muy distinto no
tenía en la presencia internacional que
tiene hoy en día la capacidad de
decisión que tiene hoy en día el
prestigio que puede contar en el
presente y cómo sería entonces una
reacción de la china actual
afortunadamente los chinos son mucho más
inteligentes ellos ejercen lo que se
llama una diplomacia inteligente sí que
es una diplomacia que no busca el
conflicto eeuu ahí tendríamos hay muchas
cosas que evaluar porque está haciendo
esto ahora en la mercè amer habla de
precisamente el realismo ofensivo como
una estrategia para distraer lo que está
pasando adentro ponerlo todo afuera y lo
que tú decías no sé cómo recuperar esa
marca de eeuu como el capitán américa
básicamente pero hay aquí si todos los
dos citas de dos estadounidenses uno es
jimmy carter cuando se restablecen las
relaciones china-eeuu el mismo dijo esto
es necesario no sólo para las buenas
relaciones china-eeuu sino para la
estabilidad de la región y del mundo hoy
en día eso es mucho más relevante que
antes porque esa china del 78 no era del
79 nueva china de hoy y la otra frase es
de kissinger no cuando él dice ser
enemigo de eeuu es terrible pero ser
amigo es fatal porque te obliga a tomar
decisiones en pro de lo que eeuu
necesita y no de lo que china quiere no
de lo que el país le conviene en taiwán
porque hablemos también que piensan los
taiwaneses en taiwán hay dos posturas y
curiosamente parece pues lo poco que
podemos ver uno en taiwán no se hizo
tanto tanto relevo a la noticia de que
venía pero si no se hizo tanta bulla
porque no querían tensionar más las
cosas con con china pero los mismos
taiwaneses dicen todos somos chinos
nosotros no queremos un conflicto
nosotros lo que queremos es en algún
momento algo pasará entonces esos en
esos conflictos
es que lo mejor es dejar los críticos y
ya si pero taiwán uno no es una política
no es un país independiente y eso
tenemos que tenerlo claro legalmente no
lo es como tus explicadas en la
introducción y entonces ante eso en si
lo miramos objetivamente derecho
internacional si eeuu está invadiendo
territorio chino line entonces desde ese
lugar claro yo no voy a armar una guerra
pero si yo hoy no te muestro mis aviones
y misiles pues tú vas a decir ah no pasa
nada y me vas a forzar y es que a la luz
de
washington o del entendimiento de este
conflicto es igual lo que está haciendo
rusia apoyándonos separatistas en el
donbass estados unidos estaría podrían
dar los separatistas de taiwán desde
desde la óptica de villena adelante y de
hecho tenemos postura prudente dentro de
la propia taiwán el actual alcalde de
taipei que aspira eventualmente a ser
presidente él también ha dicho no
queremos que nos mientan o nos fuercen a
una situación incómoda él está siendo
muy prudente porque hay relaciones
comerciales que taiwán venden muchos
productos a la propia china x obviamente
un mercado importantísimo temas
diplomáticos temas de cultura etcétera y
él
personas que ha llamado a la prudencia
en este caso también hay que decir que
hay ciertos sectores críticos dentro de
la opinión pública norteamericana eeuu
que dicen que esta es una jugada
terrible por parte del gobierno
demócrata no hay ante están un poquito
fustigando a nancy pelosi y a white
agente nancy pelosi también tiene una
vieja tradición en en general ya vimos
este tipo de polémicas ella pues con
razón o no ella fue las personas que
protestó ya en los años 90 contra contra
los problemas de la represión sociales
al estudiantado en la plaza de tiannamen
y en su momento ha defendido la posición
del dalai lama ha sido cercana un poco a
la defensa de la pluralidad del budismo
y otras posiciones llamémoslo que no
siempre son reconocidas del todo por el
por la rigidez entre comillas ideológica
de la china pero se ha sumado esto para
justamente también hacerlo ver que no
todo el blanco y negro que hay posturas
distintas también y críticas en parte de
los actores que estamos mencionando
justamente se le quería preguntar josé
alejandro sí
parte de esta tensión y este malestar en
beijing es que precisamente quien
aterrizó en taipei es nancy pelosi
precisamente por estos antecedentes
porque ya ha sido muy crítica con
beijing por el tema de derechos humanos
por el tema del manejo de minorías ha
señalado a nivel internacional la china
es esto tiene algún componente
particular o esto habría sucedido de
pronto con cualquier funcionar creo que
ella lo dijo muy bien cuando tenemos una
posición diplomática que hay que cuidar
y hay una suerte de unidad llamémosla
diplomática en la china es una sola y en
eeuu también obviamente es una nación a
nación pero resulta que en la teoría
tenemos un sistema donde hay división de
poderes en el estado de derecho y la y
la rama legislativa puede llegar a tener
cierta vocería obviamente no podemos
llegar a la exageración de romper los
canales diplomáticos del señor byron es
jefe de gobierno e jefe de estado como
en cualquier sistema presidencial pero
yo creo que ella era la persona
justamente con con el currículo para
generar este paso y no tener miedo a
hacerlo ya es una persona muy importante
en la política doméstica ella es hija de
gente que provenía de la zona de
baltimore que llegó a los ángeles que
conoce las relaciones internas ella
estaba cuando se posesionó
una jovencita y yo creo que está también
en la etapa tan alta en su carrera ya es
una señora de unos 82 años y que no le
tenemos miedo a jugar a hacer jugar
estas cartas en nombre ella misma o
finalmente lo que le está cuidando la
espalda guste o no al señor baile de una
manera que se pueda jugar que ya tiene
un respaldo de una enorme potencia sólo
por dar algunos datos ya que éste habla
del tema económico las empresas
taiwanesas han invertido cerca de 60 mil
millones de dólares en china hay un
millón de ciudadanos taiwaneses que
viven en el continente o en la china
continental y muchos están dirigiendo
allí fábricas de empresas taiwanesas que
producen en territorio continental y
pues si se produce un tipo de conflicto
allí en la carga económica sería
bastante comprometedora para para taiwán
en ese caso ya solamente con las últimas
restricciones de los últimos días han
perdido unos 640 millones de dólares por
35 en empresas exportadoras de taiwán
hacia china que han tenido que salir el
producto pueden ustedes reírse y
galletas y pasteles es el principal
producto de exportación de taiwán a asia
continental increíble pasemos a hablar
de un punto importante unas
declaraciones de nancy pelosi a su
llegada a taipei y ella dijo que aquí lo
que se está viendo es otro escenario de
enfrentamiento entre la elección entre
la autocracia y la democracia esta
competencia a nivel internacional esta
lucha de poderes a nivel internacional
mismo escenario- ucrania creo que
ustedes lo pueden confirmar esta guerra
hasta donde nos puede llevar que está
quienes están luchando aquí quien está
enfrentándose y quién está ganando esto
primero que todo tenemos que tener claro
que esto es un invento literal de eeuu
porque para que estemos en una nueva
guerra fría de autocracia versus
democracia tendríamos que tener un
beijing que ha dicho en algún lado y por
los retó a buscarlo busquen un discurso
oficial o semi oficial desde el 78 hasta
hoy si en algún momento china ha dicho
quiero hacer una guerra contra la
democracia nunca si china tiene un tema
de territorialidad de soberanía sobre
taiwán pero no tiene nada ningún
problema con la democracia si ni quiere
implantar un sistema no democrático en
taiwán ni nada por el estilo todo eso
son cosas que nos dicen para hacernos
creer que estamos entrando en una guerra
fría por qué por qué por qué conviene
más disfrazar esto de lucha por la
democracia y la libertad como se ha
hecho con irak o afganistán y demás
conviene más disfrazar lo de eso que
hablar honestamente estamos luchando
porque no queremos que nuestro poder en
el mundo disminuya entonces y más que
eso es un tema de tenemos unos temas
internos nos importa 5 lo que pasa con
el mundo creo yo es me importa mi forma
muy fácil de decir lo que pasa en eeuu y
hay un concepto que no se habla mucho
pero que es muy importante que se llama
el concepto de la excepcionalidad
norteamericana y es que eeuu de alguna
manera cree que porque es eeuu muchas de
las normas internacionales no aplican a
ellos que yo puedo demandar un drone y
matar a este señor soy yo puedo ir a
este país aunque me digan que no porque
somos eeuu y quien nos dice que no pero
este discurso cada vez pierde más
aliados también porque cada vez genera
más tensiones ahorita lo estábamos
viendo en las noticias económicas que le
está pasando a europa gracias a la
guerra con ucrania hasta qué punto le ha
convenido no entonces este concepto
digamos
afecta bastante no como la visión que
todo el mundo tiene sobre lo que está
pasando y es como a ver esto no es una
guerra democracia autocracia no tiene
nada que ver si esto es un tema soberano
y de poder punto o se alejan dro por acá
por este lado empieza que estoy estoy en
acuerdo con la posición que da ella pero
esto no resta que llamémoslo desde
occidente aunque a veces nos paramos en
la arrogancia decir desde occidente
nuestro modelo que construimos desde la
democracia de los negros de pericles
entonces podemos mirar al mundo por ese
mal hombre no es cierto eso creo que no
es válido y tenemos que gustar o no
respetar esa china de dos mujeres una
china hacia adentro
llamémoslo comunista que mantenemos con
una hacia afuera que también se haga se
abrió al gran mercado mundial pero de
todos modos en los tiempos recientes que
corren si es una oportunidad para que
reflexionemos sobre nuestra democracia
lo que pasó justamente también entre
ucrania los enfrentamientos con rusia
etcétera todas estas cosas nos hacen
pensar cuál es el modo democracia porque
si no la cuidamos desde adentro y eso
implica también un espejo para la misma
para los mismos estados unidos para
mismo reino unido- ahorita con la salida
de boris johnson etcétera es cómo vamos
a fortalecer nuestra democracia si no
tenemos ese panorama
tico desde adentro no vamos a poder
llamémoslo criticar al resto de la
humanidad y por supuesto la referencia
es tan importante no podemos dejar de
lado pues el movimiento que hubo frente
al qaeda
al dar de baja llamémoslo a la persona
que había sucedido en line esto es una
demostración de fuerza que estaba
guardada desde hacía rato entonces esas
sensibilidades pero mucho cuidado con
cuando decimos eso desde occidente
miramos desde afuera pero repetimos
tenemos que mejorar la casa eso también
implica otras regiones del mundo que nos
llama a mudar democracias posee
alejandro y que tanto terreno ha ganado
este modelo chino de un país comunista
pero con una economía abierta que
levantó de las cenizas un país
gigantesco pero tenemos la otra cara de
la moneda y es que taiwán es un país
capitalista que también tiene un modelo
económico bastante exitoso que comercia
con diferentes países alrededor del
mundo pese a no ser un estado reconocido
y las restricciones que tiene pero que
tanto terreno gana está esta forma yo
creo que tengo más dudas porque es por
supuesto son válidas todas las críticas
que hacemos a la democracia liberal
llamar se escribió desde el siglo 19 y
obviamente la china hizo una revolución
no basada en un proletariado como era
llamémosla un artista original para
países que vayan a cazar la
industrialización hacer la movida jeque
lianas de tesis antítesis síntesis el
modelo chino estuvo más basado por
supuesto en el modelo campesino y eso
también se llevó a exportar a los
experimentos revolucionarios de américa
latina no inclusive dentro de un país
como colombia con tanta diversidad
guerrillera había un movimiento más
socialista urbano había uno más de
carácter clásico marxista otro más
inclusivo y otro chino pero ese modelo
creo que tampoco es es para llegar a
exportar en la actualidad a otros a
otras revoluciones que han lo han
logrado
taiwán obviamente está como entre ese
limbo pero ese modelo yo creo que es muy
propio de ellos aunque podría ser el
salvavidas al que eventualmente podría
aspirar aspirar la revolución cubana u
otros modelos pero yo creo que no es muy
aplicable si ha pasado el tiempo rusia e
implosionó lo hizo acaba su momento
corea el norte creo que vive aislada y
nosotros experimentos de orden más de
orden social y no más radical creo que
no tiene el mismo potencial por supuesto
ya industrializado y potente económico
que les permita dar este esta doble vida
hablemos línea de posiciones de los
vecinos en el sector digámoslo así si
esto empieza a escalar cómo se pueden
repartir allí las cargas eeuu tiene
importantes militares en el pacífico
presencia militar en japón y hay que dar
un dato importante la cantidad de carga
mundial que se mueve a través del mar de
china que sale precisamente de los
puertos chinos es fundamental por no
decirlo de otra forma para la economía
del planeta entero o sea sería una zona
importante y nos afectaría a todos si se
desarrolla un conflicto si un conflicto
en ese conflicto en el estrecho de
taiwán sería terrible para el mundo no
solamente para china o para taiwán o
para eeuu sería terrible para el mundo
curiosamente bueno claro están los
aliados tradicionales corea del
sur-japón obviamente pues taiwán que
sería como los aliados bueno y
obviamente singapur y no como hay unos
aliados tradicionales podemos sumarle
india que es recientemente más aliado de
lo que era antes para contener a china
es verdad aún así eeuu sabe a lo que
juega porque en el único escenario en el
que eeuu en el que en teoría china no es
más fuerte que eeuu es en el militar a
pesar de ser la segunda la segunda
fuerza militar la distancia sigue siendo
bastante grande sólo hay un aspecto o
dos en los que china sobrepasó eeuu
estratégicamente no son sin nada del
otro mundo en términos del poder y
entonces en ese sentido eeuu sabe que es
como el el talón de aquiles si quisiera
desestabilizar china pero ni japón ni
corea del sur y singapur ni nada ellos
quieren este conflicto porque todos se
verían profundamente afectados porque en
la región la digamos la motivación de la
guerra es todo lo contrario a lo que la
región que es una región que está
creciendo y que ha tenido todo su modelo
basado en la cooperación acaban de
firmar hace un año el arse el tlc más
grande del mundo y donde todos están
incluidos ellos lo que piensan es en
cooperación y taiwán por ejemplo además
de es uno de los principales productores
de semiconductores que es fundamental
dentro de la red dentro del objetivo que
tiene hacia volverse más independiente
de eeuu en términos de innovación
tecnológica sí entonces en este sentido
a nadie le conviene este conflicto y
aquí yo jugaría lo de kissinger no me
toca por ser amigo a eeuu a apoyar o qué
hago al respecto entonces la verdad no
creo que vayamos a llegar hasta allá
porque eso requeriría de una china
reactiva lo cual no creo que vaya a
suceder no es la forma virtual no es la
forma expuesta de una extensión aquí es
importante
jose alejandro es en lo que discutieron
los países que pertenecen a la otan de
extender la otan hacia el pacífico esto
no estaría como un común antesala eeuu
tratando de tentar un poco a china cómo
reacciona ante un escenario adverso para
luego eeuu justificar y decir se lo
dijimos beijing es agresivo tenemos que
tener presencia yo creo que hay que con
prudencia pero si la otan está como en
un momento ya me moló expansivo pero
todavía yo no creo que va a llegar hasta
allá creo que primero lo que tiene que
también hacer en europa es fortalecer
como estamos viendo su política de
defensa en un país como alemania está
saliendo del corsé de que todos
conocemos después de la segunda guerra
mundial para afianzar otras políticas
pero eventualmente también la propia
otan puede llegar a tener una posición
diversa con europa como fue con el
gobierno de trump es decir está estos
elementos que estamos viendo estas
crisis ya de alguna manera las había
alentado en el propio trump yo creo que
en el lado está no va a ser imprudente
si bien está la posibilidad en caso de
que se diera llamémoslo una muestra más
de poder o de rivalidad pero yo creería
que si eso pasara pues estaríamos ante
la antesala de un mundo muy peligroso le
añado un dato a alemania ya dijo que
apoyaría a taiwán en caso de que esto se
fuera un poco más y se creciera esta
atención y llegaran de pronto aún a un
conflicto o algo o un escenario más
complicado ya vamos llegando a la recta
final del programa esto se fue volando
quiero entonces que así como tuvimos
punto de partida pues tenemos punto de
llegada y son las conclusiones de lo que
puede en los próximos días en la
respuesta que pueda haber de beijing en
las próximas horas sobre este tema y que
pueden decir desde washington o si esta
escalada simplemente va a empezar a
bailar un poco con el paso de las horas
como lo vuelven bueno china ya publicó
las coordenadas dijo que entre el 4 y el
7 de agosto va a estar haciendo
ejercicios militares razón por la cual
prohíbe que cualquier embarcación aérea
o marítima esté por esos lugares
efectivamente para debe evitar pues que
uno lanza el misil y que caiga donde en
el barco de no sé quién citó no entonces
china está haciendo súper clara y
contenida voy a reaccionar voy a mostrar
mi fuerza y la voy a mostrar aquí aquí y
aquí para que no haya efectos
colaterales si osa como que sólo es
porque necesito mostrar mi fuerza en
este momento entonces la postura de
china va a ser cómo mostrar fuerza para
que no crean que no voy a reaccionar
pero por otro lado pero dejar que se
enfríe el asunto lo más pronto posible y
desde el punto de vista de washington
pues la verdad creo yo que dirás tú
ellos van a buscar entonces ahora otras
cosas van a seguir
van a seguir la ruta de cómo generamos
otros puntos de atención para manipular
un poco hacia las elecciones que vienen
ahora entonces no creo que esto vaya a
escalar a mayores en este momento se
sigue escalar a sería un accidente
literalmente o sea sería que alguien
mató al que no debía
sin culpa sí pero no creo que en
términos conscientes ninguno de los dos
ni china ni eeuu quiera que esto
efectivamente se vuelva una
confrontación en este momento por este
lado para el cierre de sociales también
diría que estamos atravesando un
reacomodamiento de las fichas e insisto
creo que hasta que no termine la
confrontación lamentable entre ucrania y
rusia no vamos a tener una escalada
mayor que nadie está buscando
efectivamente pero sí estamos
desafortunadamente ante el mundo
inflacionario un mundo con las bolsas
afectadas con los negocios y
desafortunadamente estas viandas
maravillosas que producen en la
pastelería taiwanesa pues sí nos
llegasen al resto del mundo que las
disfruta estaríamos viviendo un mundo
peor
y bueno y aquí nos falta una pieza
fundamental taiwán que respuesta va a
dar entonces taiwán a todo esto yo muevo
por la prudencia del alcalde de taipei
que está diciendo si está muy bien está
bien que vengan acaba bienvenidos pero
tampoco queremos pelear con con la china
no estamos en una posición también de
tránsito de estabilización de nuestra
economía que ha sufrido también
desgastes y estamos en un mundo también
de mucho desarrollo y no queremos
afectar esa relación pero por supuesto
ellos tienen una clave es occidente que
no quieren que ese respaldo se ausente
se debatirá una respuesta de taiwán así
de acuerdo no la la mayoría usa la
postura de taiwán además que hay quienes
lo han dicho abiertamente nosotros no
queremos ser un juguete de eeuu para
mantener su hegemonía si en qué sentido
que le pasó a ucrania la dejaron tirada
apenas empezó si le ofrecieron un montón
de cosas y miren como están
taiwán sabe que se vería terriblemente
afectado si algo sucediera en ese
sentido no quieren ser un juguete eeuu
sin por eso significa o sea igual
quieren el apoyo todo lo que tienen
entonces es mantenerlo muy bien muy
tranquilo no darle mucho revuelo como
les digo en taiwán casi inicia blog de
esta visita o sea se ha hecho más ruido
internacional que dentro de taiwán y
obviamente una vez se va a pelosi y
demás viene todo el proceso fuera de
cámaras de calmar la situación con
beijing que eso es algo que va a suceder
pienso yo que aquí poniendo un poco de
mi opinión que no suelo hacerlo es que
el ruido internacional es porque no
sabemos cómo puede reaccionar china como
no la hemos visto en un escenario tan
complicado o difícil en donde se vea
dispuesta a sacar a sus militares no
sabemos cómo va a reaccionar el caso
distinto como pasa con rusia que es
distinto de la forma de actuar me quedan
pocos segundos por favor si tenía algo
para decir no salió esperemos que
también el mundo dé un paso más adelante
otra agenda salgamos un poco este año
complicado volver a hablar de la
cooperación que estamos viendo con la
salud con el cob y las aventuras
espaciales entre entre los amigos de la
que nos ayudamos todos yo creo que es el
mundo el que tenemos que apuntarle tarde
o temprano pues esa línea luna ya jose
alejandro zepeda les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros ustedes muchas
gracias por la sintonía sigan con la
programación de france 24
[Música]